- Good morning, Believe Nation!
It's Evan.
My one word is believe.
And I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So, to help you on your journey,
today's message is live in the moment.
Over to you, Conor McGregor.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I don't like to think too far ahead.
- [Interviewer] So, you haven't
thought alternative careers?
- No, I don't like thinking too far ahead.
People set, like, goals,
long-distance goals.
That's too much for me.
I already feel like I'm livin'
it and then I just carry on,
doing that.
You know, carry on day by day,
already living the final goal,
the goal of being the world champion.
I already carry myself like
I'm the world champion.
I already speak like I'm a world champion
and that's it.
I just carry on, day by day,
so I'll take it as it comes.
Again, like you said, you were
asking me about the future,
I'll let you know a little bit
closer, you know what I mean?
All I can see right now is the gold.
That's all I can see.
- I don't put much faith in
five-year or 10-year plans.
It's one of the most common
questions I get asked,
when I do interviews.
"What are you going to do in five years?
Where do you see your YouTube
channel being in five years
or 10 years?"
I have no idea.
I don't know if I'll still be
doing YouTube in five years
or ten years.
I think what's really important
is that you have a mission
of something you're trying to accomplish,
a general direction that you
want to go, and some big goal
that you're trying to reach,
but then not be so attached
to how you're going to
go out and accomplish it
and so, I want to help
a billion entrepreneurs.
Conor McGregor, I want us to
win the world championship,
great.
I want to help a billion entrepreneurs.
How I get there doesn't matter, right?
I've got to do something that
I enjoy, that I have fun doing,
that I feel is having a big impact,
but, the specifics doesn't matter.
And so, I know my long
term of where I'm going
and then I know what I'm
working on right now.
You know, at the end of
the year, I want to try
to have a million subscribers.
Every week, I'm creating
content, making videos,
for you guys and I make kind
of minor changes along the way
and introduce new things and new ideas.
But am I still going to be
on YouTube in five years?
I don't know.
What am I going to be doing
in five years or 10 years?
I'm going to be doing something awesome,
to help reach a billion entrepreneurs.
That's what I'm going to be doing.
That's what motivates me.
And so I think it's great
to have plans, right?
Planning is great.
It's not that you don't
want to have any plans.
You don't want to have any goals.
You want to just wake
up and see what happens,
'cause most people don't just wake up
and do something amazing.
You know, having some kind of plan,
having some kind of structure,
helps you on the days when
you're not really motivated.
This is important.
Whenever I feel like what
I'm doing is out of whack,
doesn't feel right anymore, I'm
yearning for something else,
you know, you get that little
frustration bubbling up
that I want to add something else in
and my current schedule
doesn't allow for it.
Whenever I feel like that,
then I have to re-jig my schedule.
I've got to figure out, okay,
what no longer serves me
and what am I yearning for
and how can I put that in?
And I can't plan for that.
That's the challenge.
You don't know what kind of
person you're going to be
in five years or 10 years or
what's going to interest you
or the new things that have come out.
You know, 10 years ago, YouTube
wasn't even a big thing.
If it was I want to help
a billion entrepreneurs,
I'm going to do that
by getting on MySpace,
which was all the rage 10 years ago.
Then, who cares if I'm the
number one MySpacer right now?
It's not going to help me achieve my goal
of helping a billion entrepreneurs.
And so I think having a specific target
can really be helpful,
in terms of you accomplishing that target,
but it doesn't mean that that's
actually going to help you
with your long-term goals.
And so, I'd be stubborn
about the big thing
that you're trying to
accomplish, but be flexible
in the how.
The other thing that I
have a really hard time,
and maybe this is for you guys
too, is whenever I set a goal
that might be multi-years out,
I initially, immediately
already want to think of how
to accomplish that right now.
I would look at a five-year
goal and say how do I do that
in five months.
How do I get that happening faster?
Even just the idea of
something coming into my head
of something that I want to do one day,
I start taking action
on it, just naturally.
If I wanted to build a house,
I wanted to build a custom,
modern house from scratch
and, like, yeah, that would
be good to do one day.
Just having that thought in my head, boom!
Within a year, I had my own
custom house being built.
It just starts to happen
and I think getting used
to taking action on your ideas
is also really super important.
Those plans that you have
for five or 10 years,
they don't have to be five or 10 years.
If you took action and started
doing stuff on it right now,
you can make that happen
in five months or less,
maybe five weeks or five
days, for some of you,
if you actually started
taking action on it.
And so, again, I think it's important
to be stubborn about what
you want to accomplish,
'cause you're going to need it.
You're going to need to be stubborn.
You're going to need to face
criticism and face your fears
and get up every day and do action,
but be flexible on the how
and I would strongly encourage you,
if you have a five-year goal
or a 10-year goal for yourself,
raise your standards
and start asking yourself how
do I hit that in five months?
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious,
what is your five- or 10-year goal
that now you want to
condense down to five months?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out and,
if you leave a comment
within the first few hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Michael Pedersen.
Michael, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I hope you enjoyed the read
and it really, really,
really means a lot to me.
Thank you, guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typewriter clicks)
- I've had seasons where I've
had the worst surgeries ever.
You know, I've been through,
I had seven surgeries.
You know and that alone,
you ask yourself time and time again,
how do you bounce back from
that year in and year out?
But I've always used it as,
you know, taking that time
to strengthen myself.
I never knew I was going to play 17 years.
You know, who could've ever thought that?
You don't say, when
you come into a league,
you don't say, "You know what,
I'm going to play 17 years."
And you don't even think of it that way.
You just say I'll take it year by year.
And that's what I try to tell kids.
Don't move to next year too fast.
Just like don't go to tomorrow too fast.
Deal with today.
Deal with right now.
You know, we've been in the locker room
and we're at practice and I'm like,
"Listen, put the phones down,
'cause these moments will go too fast."
And when they're gone,
they're gone, you know?
So, before you look up, you're
in two, three, five, seven,
10, 12, if you make it that long.
- Right.
- Because most of them don't.
You know, just like you
spoke about earlier.
Most of these young babies
never see five years,
never see seven years,
never less a 10-year career.
You know, so you try to
prepare them to understand
what the moment actually feels like
and that's why I think, honestly,
why my career lasted so
long, 'cause I always lived
in the moment.
Like nothing else mattered to
me and I was selfish at times,
because, even towards my
family, nothing else mattered
when it came to that.
When it came to that, I was dialed in.
It's a heck of a blessing to be here now.
I'm walking.
I'm healthy, you see.
- Still making an impact.
- Absolutely.
- Right.
- Absolutely, so, you
know, I just tell people
I don't know how long
whoever's going to play,
but I will say enjoy every moment.
Don't rush too fast.
You know, let your years
take care of your years,
but go year by year, go day
by day, go hour by hour,
go minute by minute.
- A Head Full of Dreams.
The tour's going on now.
You just got off the South American line
- [Chris] Yeah.
- I mean, the crowds,
the show, does it ever,
how do you keep it fresh, because
it's not your first rodeo.
It's your thousands, 10 thousands.
I mean, you've been doing it.
- Well, here's how we keep it fresh.
Bruce Springsteen, apparently,
I don't know if he really does or not,
used to say to the rest
of the E Street Band,
this could be someone's first show
and it could be someone's last show,
so let's treat it like that.
So, I have that inspiration
and then some other things
in my life that just make me,
but every time before we go on stage,
I really think about who's showed up,
how much they've been
through to get there.
- [Zach] Wow.
- And also for us, at the
moment, we took a break
from touring on the last album
we did called Ghost Stories,
so we're so excited to be there
and we know that nothing lasts forever,
so I think that we're just
really, more than ever,
living in the moment and
trying to appreciate the fact
that for some people it's their first show
and some people, you know.
- [Zach] Yeah.
That has to be a perspective
that that's not immediate,
right?
You learn that perspective.
- We have to work
to that perspective.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- We definitely went through
a period about 10 years ago
of feeling like what are we doing?
You know, we're questioning
everything and not really able
to take in the joy of it.
- [Zach] That's must've been hard.
- Well, everything's in
perspective, but, for us as a band,
it was a bit hard.
But slowly, you just keep going
and you find great people,
who come in and help you
out and teach you things.
And I think the more that you let in,
it's very easy right now with social media
to let in anything negative, you know.
Whatever you do, someone is
going to slag it off online.
- Well, you're not on social media at all.
- [Chris] Personally.
I mean, we are as a band.
- As a band.
Personally, I'm not that good at selfies.
(everyone laughs)
- That's the honest answer.
- So I made a decision that,
well, it's easy to take in the bad stuff,
so I'm going to really take in
the good stuff and appreciate.
These people have shown up
and they want to sing our songs
together and that's great.
I'm into it. (laughs)
- [Zach] It can't ever get old.
- So, it's very fresh.
It never gets old, that's the thing.
It never gets old.
- Funny thing about gigs is
there are so many factors
that make a great gig.
Like, I've come off stage so many times,
thinking that was awful,
for whatever reason.
You know, your sound man will
come in that was out front
and say, "That's the best
thing I've ever seen."
You go, "Really?!"
(interviewer laughs)
Or then you'll be off stage
and think that your band has
played great and you've really
and the sound man will come in
and say, "Oh, I lost the bass
for six songs."
And you're like, "Really?!"
Or the lighting man will say,
"Yes, well, the lights didn't work."
So, you know what I mean?
It's kind of, I don't really judge gigs.
While I'm doing it, I'm just in the moment
and I'm singing the songs
and when I come off stage,
I don't like talking about it.